bet you can't keep up with me
[Music]
so
what
oh
how awful
the abyss order
enemies of the human race
even the underground networks rarely
come across in the information on them
with that said it was a bit of a hassle
but i managed to dig up a few clues
really that quickly
you really are well connected master g
luke
come to think of it mr big animal god
barbados
why exactly do you need the help of mere
humans uh
how do i put it
the seven as people now know them were
once known as the seven arkhans
each archon presides over their own part
of tavat
that is the role the archons play only
in performing this duty can we attain
power but i don't like the idea of
ruling monstat and i don't feel monstat
would really like it either
go forth and establish a city of freedom
without rule
we have not forgotten barbados wish for
monstat
gene you're such a devotee
maybe someone got a little too free and
is just too lazy to care
uh
however it may have come to be i haven't
been back to monstat for an extended
period of time
without a doubt i am now the weakest
darkone among the seven
you flatter me
oh such a humble god
is it a blessing or a curse
but we digress
let's get back to the topic at hand the
common enemy of all mankind
we have tracked the abyss mage to the
vicinity of the winery
i cannot stress enough how important it
is to not let it escape
no
it can't be
[Music]
right
uh
[Music]
you're in for a little shock
come a little closer
huh
huh
what's this
after the abyss mage was defeated a
certain energy dispersed from its body
it seems that energy was being used to
cut off the connection between me and
deval
huh
do you know of storm terrorism
of course i believe the people of
monstat all know of it
after davalan woke up he took the
ancient ruins as his lair
as it was with the storms that
previously cut monstat off from the
outside world the entrance to the ruins
is also sealed by a special barrier
but now as the energy dispersed from the
abyss mage i was able to read the
rhythmic flow of how the barrier's magic
was woven
i must admit it sounds even more
horrendous than a chorus of hilly
charles but
it should be enough to let us break
through the storm barrier and reach
storm terror's lair which means we're
going to confront divalent
i'm fine with that
gene is the one who wishes to avoid any
direct confrontation
no when there are no other options left
it is my responsibility to alter our
course of action if slaying him is our
only choice i will gladly become the
knight that leads the charge
fortunately we have yet to need to go
that far
hmm
by that
you mean i mean that the holy liar is
not our trump card
our real trump card the traveler of
course
the traveler
correct
but you have a much more precious forte
the impurities and the tears and the
curse that binds divalent belong to the
same maleficent power
which means
you tone deaf bard don't you see how
crazy this is
you've seen what devon is like when he's
ticked off she'll be swallowed hold
before she even gets to look hey
nice plan worth a shot
i am with you honorary night
oh so we just need to fight monsters
from the abyss and a dragon no pressure
or anything
humans aren't without their strengths
let's go
and so
epic actions of brave heroes finally
leads to this 11th hour